a great little Italian restaurant in a
wealthy town
Charming staff top food happy customers
well
that's the dream but this is La Lanterna
[__] and it's going down the pan fast I
don't know how long
Alex Scott is so worried about his
business that he hasn't slept for four
months
[Music]
his best mate Gavin runs front of house
but he hasn't got a clue you as a major
D are [__] useless the food's
expensive the restaurant's empty most
nights and Alex is losing more than a
grand a week quick
if I can't turn this business around
then the lights will go out at Lanterna
for good it's [__] wake up time
just 20 miles north of London Letchworth
is Britain's first Garden City
slap bang in the middle of town is
Lanterna
I guess that's you're doing this one get
that should do it it's run by British
born and bred Alexander Scott
from an early age Alex dreamed of being
a chef he's a bit lemon juice on it and
put a bit olive oil over it then
childhood holidays in Italy turned him
into a self-confessed Italian fire uh
[Music]
so much so he's taken to calling himself
Alexander I think I'm a
pretty decent Chef I know it's a lot
worse and I do take a lot of pride in
what I do
we've got a really good reputation where
people travel from 40 50 miles 60 miles
to come here for a meal and we have got
a really really good name
like Gordon or Jamie or one of these
other feathers
helping him realize his Italian dream
this polish sidekick El Donna Novak
he's got more attitude
[Music]
trolley try to do everything I can to
try and build your business up
everything that I can possibly think of
and it's just not what employing friends
an exair Hostess girlfriend Emily has
proved to be a dangerous mix of business
and pleasure okay you're canceling
I've read mortgage my house again to her
inject some money into the business and
took out another personal loan and sort
of beefed up my credit cards but how
long can we last
Ed
with debts of more than 180 000 pounds
Alex is on the verge of losing
everything he's got that's quite nicely
outside
that's why I'm here to find out what's
gone wrong
Chef only Chef nice how are you very
well thank you good and this is it it is
and God it's it's small Pokey yeah very
Pokey Al Scott executive chef I like
those yeah
in the kitchen yeah to us two so that's
why the executive what's with the flags
Italian English yeah and that's the
style of food it is Italian
and you're from um Italy England oh
England there's always works in Italian
Kitchen so I just sort of learned to
learn the language learn the style of
cooking so lots of Italian ingredients
yeah where the courgettes from uh from
our butcher from London this morning but
of course yes from a butcher yes and
then where are the peppers from Tesco's
Tesco's they're cheaper are they cheaper
so uh courgettes of the butcher peppers
from Tesco's uh lemons from Sardinia
Cash and Carry so so far I've seen [__]
all Italian
that's a day the only busy night at
Lanterna a chance for me to take a close
look at Alex's authentic Italian Kitchen
a special shoes for the cannelloni
packet bechamel sauce that reminds me of
my days as a hotel comic back in the
early 80s
[Music]
a successful Italian Kitchen has to
understand the secret of great Italian
food
simple fresh Italian ingredients
what does a dollar do service
operate the microwave in Alex's kitchen
all the vegetables are pre-cooked and
blasted in the microwave
for Christmas tree decorations
when you do our sticker on the top shelf
we've got our Ferry
what turns you on about food what makes
you excited about food
in Poland were you working as a chef
the tax office yeah yeah
that's nice so why cooking I don't know
I don't I don't know I don't actually
cook
great start a police assistant who won't
cook and an English Chef who seemingly
can't
be finished but the menu promises modern
Italian cuisine and at 30 quid ahead
it's got to be good to keep the
customers coming back
if you like matchmakers
the packet grossini matches The Deco
straight out of a 1980s fake Italian
trattoria
see what Alex is made of I've asked him
to serve me up some Italian classics
first up fresh minestrone soup
this should be a star hit on any Italian
menu
very very greasy
yeah
dirty all slick around the outside I'll
pass on that one what is that oh it's
parsley on the stalk
next salcicio lagano fresh Italian
sausages baked in white wine and served
on garlic bread
and it looks like two poodle penises
doused in parsley I almost like feel
I've gone back to sort of 1982 where
every other restaurant in the High
Street was an Italian ripoff
we're now in the 21st century and
they're still serving crap like this
[Music]
[__] disgusting
even worse the Amaretto cake is brought
in and unfortunately not quite defrosted
slightly Frozen in the center
oh dear dear
this is about as authentic as a [__]
Chinese Takeaway
right Alessandro
you talk passionately about you know
Italian ingredients authenticity I saw
nothing
Italian and nothing done with care
I'm concerned about where you're going
how long this place has got to last and
unfortunately delivered [__] all
and that was way way below part
do you think this is funny
no because I didn't find it funny
that was upsetting
because that was [__] dire
Alex may think that I'm his worst
nightmare but this really is my idea of
kitchen hell
he's in such meltdown he's even let the
most basic standards of a hygiene slip
[Music]
you think you'd have cleaned up I mean
it's not as if you didn't know I was
coming
there's no excuse for Filth as bad as
this
when was the last time the place was
really properly cleaned it's cleaned
every Friday afternoon yeah [__]
when was the last time all the freezers
were pulled out
pulled out
um that was done about two weeks ago
what about all the bread rolls down
behind the fridge now you can see them
from here look that's where she throws
up into the uh well Donna throws bread
up into the basket to dry out dry out
for breadcrumbs
and she misses so it all goes down the
back of the fridge dirty lady
what about this kind of [__] here what
about them
with the kitchen in this state Alex
risks further damage to lantana's
already fragile reputation oh [__] you
know it's never been used
what about these trays there when were
they done
it could even be closed down that if we
do that yeah the oven doesn't stops
working
out are you ever gonna tell me the truth
it does don't worry about the oven
breaking yeah that's replaceable giving
a customer [__] food poisoning is not
yeah
look at that in there that is gross that
is [__] disgusting everywhere you
turn in this kitchen there's another
surprise
muscles on the floor stuff everywhere
produce just left going moldy again and
then there's a pot noodle on there who
the [__] is eating pot noodles
there's 60 Customs out there I am so
[__] glad they can't see where their
food's coming from how it's cooked what
the [__] is going on behind the scenes
because it's a mess and it's a [__]
embarrassment
[__] disgusting
oh my God that is taking the [__]
piss [__] hell
[Music]
it's my second day at Lantana where I'm
trying to drag it back from the depth of
despair
Alex has told me he's tried everything
he can to save the business the new head
chef Alexander promises exceptional food
and an enjoyable evening for every
occasion when only the very best will do
[__] me only the very best will do the
kitchen's a [__] dirty filthy mess
Exquisite classic Italian food
God what a [__] spook
radio ad is going to take a lot more
than that to get this place back on
track
when was the last time the fridges were
done last week
what is that that's finished from
Saturday nights that's just a special
order Jesus
I'm shocked by the levels of hygiene
here I wouldn't even serve that to a
[__] pig you know Alex isn't even
following the basic rules there's got to
be Mac and no matter what you're doing
from a bacon sandwich to a [__]
totally near [__] ghost cheese you
have to stay immaculate oven should be
cleaned after every service the floor
should be spotless
and leftover food should be thrown away
or stored in clearly labeled containers
oh [__] it in Hell his fingers have been
in there I I need to throw this stuff
away because I'm nervous yeah yeah yeah
with standards this look Alex's
authentic Italian Kitchen look at that
could be closed down
who is that
environmental health
environmental health no damn
Pest Control [__] me do we need you come
in yeah he knows what he's gonna do he's
just trying to check the rat cat one
Saving Grace they've never had rats or
mice in this kitchen
right yeah but there is one pest I'd
like to control and that's Alex he's
been scurrying around in his own mess
for far too long can you see where we
are now you know um I've had a very
um embarrassing dinner I've come back
into the kitchen the place is in a mess
you've taken you off the ball the
passion's gone and we've really got to
get this thing back up let's get all
that clean without any [__]
with a clean kitchen I can focus on the
main problem
Alex is cooking
[Music]
of 1970s Italian crap
because when you walk into a kitchen and
spot a bottle of lazy lemon it means
lazy bastard nothing more
for me I don't know where to [__]
start with the food you know because
what I want to do is try and store that
kind of freshness and give it a sense of
Italian
style influence yeah but Italian food
wasn't built up on [__] frozen food
run underwater yeah because quite
frankly all I've seen do so far is
reheat things I know the food's rubbish
but I need to see how he gets it on the
plate
[Music]
I've never seen a chef work at this
break net speed and yet achieve so
little
[__] you know a little fucker's got all
the energy in the world but it's just
channeled in the wrong direction because
it's actually jumping around doing [__]
all he looks [__] busy but he's
actually cooking [__] badly [__] Poco
deal
[Music]
how's my Red Bull with a diet of five
red balls a day Alex is so wide he
bashes out the food as though his life
depends on it
most of his food comes in Frozen or from
a packet and I know why
he's lazy
instead of getting ready for his
customers he'd rather play golf all day
than Rock up an hour before service with
his best mate Gavin swires
[Music]
your table of seven people of course to
seven how many's look now Gavin um I'm
gonna need to double count again Kevin
is the restaurant manager the face of
Lanterna does he know what he's doing
out there
we'll have a walk up the road because we
think we may have got the wrong place
but it looks like the dying room is
operated with about as much finesse as
the kitchen
you say you want to run it as an Italian
restaurant well
maybe 30 years ago I can understand why
this exists but not now
and quite frankly any further is it no
nowhere near it not with
those
yeah
that
those yeah well I was taught to cook
buying a very well respected Italian
chef well that's total [__] because
there was nothing Italian there nothing
anywhere
Alex tells me this well-respected Chef
is still in the area
maybe he can shed some light on the
source of Alex's inspiration
foreign
[Music]
yeah and did you introduce him to
Bechamel and Demi glass and Masala yeah
um
what
I'm the responsible one if something go
wrong [__] you now married where'd you
want me to start it turns out Alex spent
his formative years with italian-born
Mario known locally as harfordshire's
king of the chaterias and obviously went
very well because you know you're a taxi
driver
kitchen right if it doesn't work out for
Alex
I suppose I can come and bring him to
the rank
yeah because his food's [__] rank
yeah yeah see but he's allows his rival
as well he's a lousy driver as well okay
now I'll let you get back to your rank
thank you they're very soft those hands
they're like babies bottoms get back in
the kitchen Mario
it seems the extent of Alex's knowledge
of authentic Italian cuisine stretches
no further than Luton Alex needs to bite
the bullet and relaunch the Russian with
a fresh identity of his own
but a new image costs money and Alex is
at the end of his tether financially
how'd you pay yourself I haven't paid
myself a wage for four months bloody
hell I mean is your business really on
the line of going bust oh absolutely it
is very much down the line because I
lose everything the house everything
it's all it's all tied up in a business
so if it all goes wrong I walk away with
absolutely nothing
Alex's pass seems full of bad financial
decisions after just two weeks of
running Lanterna success went to his
head and instead of getting his cooker
fixed he spent 46 000 pound on a new car
[Music]
with no spare cash Alex can't afford to
turn the business around
can you [__] slow down a bit please
I'm feeling sick [__] him now
why on Earth did you buy it
truthfully I love cars
and what I'm trying to say is you think
you've got your priorities right look
down at the number plate do you have a
small deck that you're not talking about
you don't need a car for transport to
get to work no no you live above the
restaurant New commitments yeah big
responsibility absolutely [__] big
responsibility then you're going to
Splash out in a [__] car yeah
so we've got to recuperate money back to
get back into the business to keep the
business open absolutely
so we've got to sell it
I mean if you had the choice of keeping
the car and closing the business
because that's what's going to happen
shortly
to God keep the business
at last he's got his priorities right
and with the car up for sale on the
internet I've got him a good deal on a
new cooker
I need to get 38 for it to clear the
finance [__]
maybe I can bring around and see if we
get rid of that number plate please do
now let's think of a [__] grade a
class a chef
[Music]
hi Anthony
I need some help please everyone knows I
have a lot of respect for TV chef
anti-roll Thompson
not your cup of tea I didn't think it
would be you know that
and we know you're not in need of a
penis extension well well exactly that
um you're not interested
I'll give him a call Hey JC please
unless I'm trying to sell it
I'm listening to it
hold on a minute I'm gonna ask you
what's wrong with the private play then
with the car and the number plate up for
sale we can move forward
it's time to get Alex to do something he
clearly hasn't done for a very long time
I want him to start cooking
this
there's a way of taking all your
frustration out yeah in Your Graffiti
yeah Alex needs all the help he can get
and I want to see if any of his kitchen
staff have hidden talents or each of you
to make a pizza Whoever has the best
tasting Pizza will put it on the menu
tonight as a special
I've discovered that Joe the kitchen
Porter has trained as a cook explain
yours to me pepper uh-huh mushroom
mushroom cheese
nice
and Chef Alex nice Four Seasons with
artichokes screen peppers black olives
and Palmer hat with a little bit
slash bastard okay Joe here we go excuse
me do you want to come into a restaurant
to try some pizza we've just made thank
you here we go right Joe just explain to
the lady what we've done have you got
two seconds we've just made these
amazing pizzas this lady's coming to
taste and would you come in and just
taste them with us you look like a man a
little bit under nourished bring on the
pizza Alexandra and I bet you're a
vegetarian oh yeah okay all right we
have a vegetable pizza how long have you
vegetarian
what I didn't realize was that aldana
put Parma Ham on the base of her
mozzarella and tomato pizza
it's one that I tried uh the last one I
would go for that one the mozzarella one
unfortunately that's got lots of
mozzarella and tomato but underneath
that
it's Palmer ham oh no that was me no no
I didn't know that this is the lady who
made them come for her
come here
there you go see well done
your life you converted to vegetarian
yeah okay would you like some more no
thank you oh come on normally now you
haven't come out of a big rash
good luck with the Vegemite
fresh food on the menu marks a new start
for Lanterna
there's going to be a huge step for Alex
goodbye
look at that in there people are eating
that it's so strong this demographics
it's not going down
no it's all here
I'm banning all traces of plastic sauces
from the premises now Alex will have to
cook from fresh
in an attempt to slow Alex down in the
kitchen I'm cutting his menu by half why
have you got three chicken dishes on
purchase for variation trying to give
people more Choice yeah well I've seen
all three of them and I think they're
all [__] you know that because they're
all fog with the same [__] sauce two
of them can go and I'm not doing that or
saying that to put you in the [__] but
you are in a position to regenerate
rejuvenate those customers and put a
little bit of freshness and a lot of
excitement to your customers you know
that yeah
with a limited menu and some new dishes
tonight is Alex's big chance to prove to
me that he's capable of cooking from
fresh
[Music]
it's something I'd expect one of my most
Junior chefs to pull off without a hitch
hey check on one front cocktail two
parmigiano one soup four tablespoon so
normally goes like this
Jesus Christ then everyone gets really
dizzy first time oh [__] damn
slow down okay I want to really make
sure you stay nice and calm yeah yeah
let's show some composure now yeah but
the kitchen's only half the story
for the evening to run smoothly the
dining room's got to be well managed by
the major dude
but the maito D is Alex's best mate it's
Gavin's first job as a restaurant
manager and I don't think he's got a
clue
a couple options left very nice I did
have that
it doesn't help that Gavin supported
front of house by Emily Alex's
girlfriend
70 degrees and I approved it what do you
want to do anything nothing just wasn't
cold her only experience of serving food
comes from seven years as an air hostess
you've got to get some Authority around
you know that you've got to get some
presents look at those privilege over
there
that's how big your bullet should be
that big now find them and [__] use
them
just drizzle Alex yep nice and calm
oh yeah Alex isn't doing too badly
but it's not long before Gavin's way out
his depth he should be taking orders now
though huh
what is he doing out there
Gavin's managed to get 60 people booked
in for tonight
but he's allowed 40 of them to arrive at
the same time
I think we're going to be in this [__]
in 10 minutes
any manager worth his weight should know
he's got to stagger the bookings to keep
a steady flow of orders coming into the
kitchen
you're okay now yeah
[__]
scrape off a little bit
okay
what is it tell me what it is
Monday Returns
still another one under pressure all
Alex's bad habits can flooding the bags
first time in his entire career he's
actually had to cook properly and it's
pretty obvious he can't do it
completely in the [__] and lost it big
time
nothing together
and he's just clammed up and and I got a
good mind to get that number plate off
that [__] car and stick it up his ass
sideways
Alex and Gavin are like two little boys
playing at running a restaurant
I've never worked like this
I hate saying that but
so close to Cowboys you know that
quit now yeah
put the restaurant up for sale
[Music]
I'm more than halfway through my week at
Lanterna but last night's attempt at
putting freshly cooked food on the menu
proves a total disaster
Alex has a long way to go if he's going
to become a half decent Italian chef and
his mate Gavin gives an equally pathetic
performance
it's just so frustrating when you show
them time and time again the perfect
opportunity for a great local Italian
Eatery in the middle of a very wealthy
town
and you can make such a great business
out of it but
I don't know if they've got it you
jumped up little [__] prick who the
[__] do you think you are because you as
a major D are [__] useless
I've done it to upset you so you come
back to me I'm going to have to teach
Gavin how to get tough if he's going to
have any Authority tell me exactly what
you think right now I was going through
your head and get off your chairs and
his customers get it out
no there's no one here for the [__]
sake we're in the middle of a field
you've got to have authority and
customers got to walk in there looking
for you yeah and you've got to get a
reputation yeah at the moment I just see
this sort of little Lost Boy moping
around
and there's things that go on that dying
room that you should be aware of yet
you're totally clueless so I'm really
nervous that you're not supporting Alex
properly so what I want you to do is
start getting angry right why did you
send that stop that sounds like a
[__]
[__] in a choir why the golden rule
in any dining room you have to be in
control of your staff
like that and not let your staff control
you why was that food
oh that's not good enough you sound like
a right [__] limp dick what the [__]
are you doing taking the food to Table
Six not table seven
you [__] idiot can you not read the
order in the kitchen excellent Gavin
needs to gain the respect of his team so
they know who's the boss then he can
start running the restaurant with a bit
of flow no he really found your bollocks
okay give it all this time okay what are
you doing you stupid idiot where's your
[__] brain tonight is it up your ass
along this thing according to have a
Winship before Sydney notices
I think you're a dirty [__] show
anything else
oh [__] you know I want you looking
imagine okay smiling up and just lifting
that whole sort of image any chance to
give a quick cleanup yes yes don't go
too close and gets it bite
with a fresh clean Alex I want a fresh
clean look for the menu
[Music]
Alex has confessed that he doesn't eat
fresh fruit vegetables or fish
if we're ever going to make this
question work I've got to get him to
develop a better sense of taste for
decent food
get the [__] blindfolds on
I'm putting swordfish on the new menu
and I want Alex to choose the pasta that
will be served with it and you look
younger with that gun today you know
that uh a lot younger right first one
quite interesting one this one we're
starting with a strong blue cheese there
you go open white thank you there you go
nice fine noodles
go in I've I had a hint of light like
light pesto eat like pestoe
nutty I think you're [__] nut you
know that this is an intriguing one the
second one yeah she's smell what's on
there you know that open what next up
fresh herbs and olive oil definitely
freshly chopped herbs in there not a
fresh chopped herbs that's interesting
not dry it's not dried yeah that's not
bad finally something I found lurking in
Alex's ladder
okay this one so spicy
so
um that was very nice actually yeah
all right tomatoes
more Saucy than the other two but it's
still very nice out of all three
pastas which one would you serve with a
swordfish I'll tell you the last one the
last one
yeah okay last one
oh for [__] sake
Alex's taste buds are being sullied by
plastic sauces for too long
the last one was a [__] pot noodle is
it
a curry pot noodle pot noodle
got to awaken his senses and give him a
standard to aim towards
since I first met him Alex has blamed
everything but himself for his lack of
success
fresh produce so I'm taking him to a
neighborhood restaurant that sustained a
great reputation for 14 years based on
simple Italian cooking
um the chef's been here since um the
only Francesco
morning gentlemen how are you
yeah good to see you
um Alex has got a small um how would you
call it modern Italian yeah plastic
Italian restaurant in lechworth um for
me the most important thing is just to
look at the size of this kitchen yeah
this is smaller than yours yeah you
don't need a big kitchen to prepare a
good food no you've got one stove there
and what's the secret behind Italian
cuisine what is it Simplicity Simplicity
Simplicity is freshness of ingredients
no pot noodles no nope
no frozen food
oh lovely piglet lovely
rosemary garlic fennel seeds nice and
how are you serving that just with roast
potatoes I love it it's a very light
gravy and you use any bechamel sauce no
no
I've been in here five minutes I am
absolutely starving
thank you
I want Alex to taste the difference
between his Frozen bought in ravioli and
something in an Italian Kitchen can be
proud to serve
I want you to taste this
yeah
sure really nice fresh flavor pumpkin
I think stuck to the roof of your mouth
no no no
really nice Sage butter
are you capable of doing something like
this absolutely absolutely but do you
really want to do it I really want to do
it am I wasting my [__] time not
not talking you will see a big
difference it's been a big wake-up call
the last couple of days and it's gonna
get me into Focus I'm starting to focus
and get things into how they should be
and
get things working again but I'm quite
nervous because I think you'll let it
fall through your fingers it will work
some option but if it doesn't work and
you don't wake up what will you do I
will work out
and I'm telling you that in order for
you to prove me wrong and I will prove
you wrong
and before we go I mean you're a great
chef aren't you
nice car um what about the number plate
can I sell you the number plate A1 Chef
um how much is it going for the car no
the [__] number plate 1800 1800 so
would you have a private number play it
no no
either you're an A1 Chef yeah you still
won't have a plate no
so what the [__] are you doing with it
on your car
Alex has had his car number plate up for
sale for the last week and we're praying
for some good news
[Music]
unfortunately your item did not sell
yeah I was rather hoping we can get rid
of it today you know I also have a
conclusive sale yeah
it's not the result Alex was hoping for
but with Lanterna in desperate need of a
revamp I want to show him it's possible
to change the look of the restaurant
without spending lots of money
the interior was designed by Alex's
girlfriend Emily and then we've got
Rusty brickwork down the end but her
ideas seem to be based on dodgy hotels
she stayed in as a charter flight air
hostess
for the price of a couple of tins of
paint we can rid and Turner of his 1980s
Trattoria look Charles I don't think you
should
we'll go with Emily
enemies
whose ration is it is it yours and Alex
there's Alex's Restaurant it was Emily's
Last Choice it was ghastly so I think
she should have less of an involvement
next time around you don't trust me well
it's not because I don't trust you I
think it needs to be a substantial
Improvement Emily comes pale walls Alex
is your restaurant
get your Goonies out and make a decision
I like to go darker
it's lanterna's first birthday tomorrow
night and a perfect opportunity to
relaunch the restaurant but in order to
make it work Alex has to be completely
committed to his kitchen it's really
exciting making nice homemade soups yeah
and when you think of Italian
restaurants you always think of stuff
being homemade I'm replacing the
disgusting minestrone soup the rich
Tuscan bean soup instead of the menu yep
yeah I'll Donna read the menu
I've slimmed down the menu from a
three-page epic to a simple handful of
classic Italian dishes all freshly
cooked by Alex
[Music]
and I've cut these prices to give value
for money not a concept Alex has ever
been familiar with and that sets you up
with 15 to 20 portions of soup at four
pounder portion of flavor 80 pound
return that you've got to put 12 to 15
minutes love into it yeah it's [__] off
I want Alex to have every chance of
making it a success
just see how elegant that is nice and
wide Kevin would you reckon
the paper tablecloths cost next to
nothing and the paintings come courtesy
of a local art college Alice what do you
think it's [__] bollocks isn't it it
just looks great absolutely
with a fully booked restaurant for the
relaunch comes Alex's chance to forge a
new reputation okay guys big nine new
menu yep lots of exciting fresh
ingredients new dining room so walking
around with a little bit of Grace and
put a bit of passion into it yeah as if
you really want it yeah this is
lanterna's last bite at the Cherry okay
Tuscan bean soup very simple if Alex and
his troops can remember what I've taught
them and there's just a chance tonight
might be a success
okay can we just highlight the bottom of
the menu here very very quickly today's
celebration the first anniversary
Lantana restaurant from now on Alexandra
Scott will not be using microwaves or
synthetic sauces and I so [__] mean
that you know that yeah yeah okay ready
yep let's go good luck just really
helping out then I can't make any
mistakes I really want to get it right
just uh someone couldn't say yeah you
did good we're okay okay he's good Alex
has got all the right ingredients here
to make a bloody good business but can
you pull it off
[__] nose
yes yes that's better
no no no we filled a dining room with
some of Letchworth local dignitaries but
as the guests start piling in one suit
once the cracks in Alex's cooking begin
to show
so two sausages yeah
[Music]
Laura how's everybody out there
yeah
what are they saying about the food
I mean we've been in here now hour and a
half
rather slow
an hour and 15 minutes
can we reorder and have breakfast
instead College [__] [__]
Alex seems to be falling at the first
hurdle
[Music]
yes but we've just gone really really
really quiet you know that I've done
that
so I keep repeating everything there's
only one man who can get us out of this
mess and help Salvage then Turner's
reputation
please thank you all right Kevin
's in the [__] yeah that's pretty
obvious yeah it's a big night tonight
the night we should be in the ship hello
yeah how many linguine have you sold not
many
I don't think many as well we haven't
sold one yet yeah so in order to help
the kitchen start pushing the [__]
linguine a little bit Yeah so we can
take a bit of weight off Alex's
shoulders and push the soup as well
stuff that we can really start flying
the starters out please yeah okay sure
let's go I want Gavin to show some
bottles if he can motivate his team and
start selling the ready prepared
specials that will take the pressure off
Alex and get the kitchen back on track
well done let me just say is that easy
sold so on the squash in here now he
just sold another four Porsches hey well
done
yeah welcome back what did we discussing
the field the other day about having
what
yeah profitable balls that's exactly
that now we found them yeah excellent
all right well done yeah uh you just
made the restaurant yeah another 15 quid
by Gavin pushing the specials he's
giving Alex some space to calm down and
start cooking like a proper Chef
one blue Allah blue
get this one right especially on night
light tonight yeah yeah now for the last
two and a half hours of [__] Mayhem
yeah with the right sort of
encouragement he might just pull it off
I bet you ever cook it
I bet you [__] do I'm apologizing now
because Alex will overcook the Blue
Steak again okay sorry
classic
it's hardly dinner at the Cipriani but
it's not bad no this one's blue
and yeah and the customers are liking it
too
nice
very nice
I never thought I'd say it
but thanks to gather's Newfound
confidence the Letchworth boys have come
good
Rome wasn't built in a day but at least
I bought Alex Kicking and Screaming into
the 21st century very good
it's been excellent tonight it was
something a bit different something a
bit different about about it the source
that you know
Happy First Birthday yeah may your
second be even better
um Emily happy with the dining room
yes that is a pathetic answer that means
no I [__] hate it
um I've asked Alex to make sure that you
don't get a paintbrush in your hand
again
yes if it's a real man I'll take you
down that soon again you know that all
right say it to me once more well the
whole lot the whole [__] lot the
whole [__] lot I'm positive in front
of your colleagues where's your [__]
brain tonight is up your [__] ass why
the [__] did you take Table Six his
order it's a table seven you stupid
wanker
that's fantastic
I really want them to succeed but it'll
take a lot of commitment and hard work
to make this place a real success
cheers guys cheers
[Music]
cheers
oh you smooth bastard
[Music]
six weeks later and I can't wait to see
how things are going on how are you very
well thank you you're welcome
what's going on
Alex Scott living in a dream world I
don't know how long he believed he was a
talented Italian chef but his kitchen
was filthy I wouldn't even say that for
a [__] thing
the food was Dire and overpriced [__]
disgusting and to make matters worse his
restaurant manager Gavin was a wimp you
as a major D are [__] useless
no wonder Alex was drowning in death and
about to lose his home and his business
never worked like this you know so close
to Cowboys you know that after a week of
hard slog then Turner was reinvented and
given the potential to become a great
Neighborhood Restaurant for that
swordfish beautiful now I'm back to save
my time at Lanterna had any lasting
effect
S
no louder how are you okay follow us
crap
[__] have you been the last [__] two
months we've been [__] hanging around
waiting for you you lazy [__] bastard
how are you thank you good to see you
well that's better excellent where's Al
Donna's Christmas tree and vegetables
they all stack they're all gone now do
them all to order everything stands
order thank God those revolting
overcooked vegetables are off the menus
overall the whole stuff enthusiasm is
lifted and you look cleaner show me
nails
you know refreshed reinvented I'm happy
about what I'm doing yeah
every morning I can't believe what I'm
seeing you're getting straight down show
me surprise me Alex
yeah
that's not bad so what's that in there
that's my um mix of my arm on top so
it's just [__] me
[__] me serious I'm speechless
Alex is actually cooking
that's it down here we have a ravioli
filled with mushrooms and walnut Jesus
Christ [__] it now you're right yeah
he surprised me I don't surprise me um
you know you know a little bit sort of
surprises in shock thank you
I do think you're capable of doing it
the amounts I'm gonna spending in the
kitchen now is I'd say about four hours
more to what I was doing and the more
work and effort and the more care you
put into food
the more it hurts when it goes wrong oh
absolutely so you know it's an
interesting relationship I mean it looks
like you've now started to sort of
really wake up and understand that bond
with food each time I make like the
ravioli I'm improving every time
obviously tasting the food is is better
than using the fresh ingredients well
we've talked the talk yep now I want to
eat the [__] food okay good yeah
my hope is extra commitment in the
kitchen is reflected in the standard of
his food
you can close your eyes and actually
count flavors percepts the walnuts the
pasta very good
I'm pleased to see he's stuck to a small
very simple Italian menu and
everything's freshly cooked
this is the kind of food
real
party rustic wholesome Italian food rich
with tomatoes nice texture the meatball
I'm a perfectly cooked linguine lovely
is lechworth ready for Alex Scott
Alex has come a long way since these
plastic sources from just six weeks ago
last time you're struggling to sort of
live survive depending on credit cards
yeah in the ship yep we've cleaned I
mean Christmas we basically cleared off
all our debts all our business and
personal debts yep starting afresh
started a new year with a clear bank
balance paid off all the bad dating and
you know we're staying around two feet
now and we're having a good January
competitor everyone else in here
even though he's still got the car Alex
has managed to clear 20 000 pounds worth
of debt
big car in here now isn't it
and can finally afford to pay himself a
wage
isn't crowd yet
but there's still one thing standing in
the way of Alex's success
and that's Alex
I sincerely hope he doesn't try to run
before he can walk
yes Alex you are an A1 [__] that's what
good Lino
Le
unfortunately just um
veal and we'll pass that one please
between them they've learned how to
crack the egg battered to [__] literally
he was hoping quite a nice big piece of
eight wheels and there's no texture but
apart from that
very nice but they haven't yet made the
omelette yeah
cooking now for six weeks because that's
all I'm gonna say that you're cooking
properly for six weeks and it takes
years
oh yeah absolutely please don't forget
that oh no it's a big wake up call
grandchariver just really sort of put me
out to what can be done on small
premises yeah using fresh ingredients
what you're saying is that you're no
longer
[__] Cowboy absolutely
100 so when you think that things are
going perfectly right and you don't
really need to improve think back the
days of powdered stock but you always
learn about you put the shits up
yourself because there's gonna be no one
here
in five minutes to do that for you do it
yourself now yeah absolutely I'm looking
for your help really appreciate it
that's all thank you Just One Last Thing
Before I Go
Gary
hi mate's Gordon how are you I don't
maintenance I need a favor I'm a little
bit in the [__] to be honest now Gary
Rose is truly an A1 Chef I can give it
to you for 2 998 pounds
[Music]
hold on a minute you've got a number
plate with you haven't got the same have
you
got 22 Dr
[__] it
okay
okay mate 500 quids listen 500 quid I'll
go back to him 500 quid and hopefully we
sold the [__] thing
D Place cafe bar is Indie [__] people
don't eat out that surely are you taking
the piss we give it a bit of a Polish
we're gonna do horrible food let's do
horrible food all the time
about this in front he'll hang you
upside down from the other tree on by
your follow-ups you know I've got just
seven days to transform the food and
banish the [__] you know the oven's
not even hot enough to roast a potato
[__] Burger in there but the staff
are warm yeah
[Music]
and if I'm gonna get this place back on
track
something's got to give those aren't
interested in pulling on the [__]
rope [__] off are you heading off of
this hang on
are you ready for this yes
yes big day don't [__] it up
Essex an ancient Saxon County more
recently colonized by Essex girls boy
races and footballers wives and now I'm
Mexican Colleen Dave called Israel find
out what it is not here
five years ago he bought trendy Fusion
Cuisine to the heart of Chelmsford he
opened D Place cafe bar and it seemed
that he had found a winning formula
great place great music great service
great food the right price
and he worked perfectly over the space
of two years Israel built a mini Empire
of five businesses
but success didn't last long
three years later all but the plays are
gone even this place is hanging on by a
thread if I don't do something drastic
then you know this business will go down
the pan
having invested a hundred and fifty
thousand pounds and with a quarter of a
million pound loan from the national
Brewery Israel and his partner Tara are
at the Wit's End so you've had the
success though
almost pissed through your hands classic
example in business trying to run before
you could walk without consolidating how
quiet is it it's as bad as it's ever
been the restaurant's losing money the
the bar is supporting the restaurant
ourselves have dropped by more than 50
percent in comparison to two years ago
and desperate to get it back
very very desperate I'm at the
crossroads dude I still give you another
go or do I return the keys to the
landlord next month and say
I probably can't do something else
we don't know the kind of guy that will
give in easy no I don't
Israel is up to his neck in debt and
doesn't even have the security of owning
the building if this goes tits up he and
Tara will lose everything
[Applause]
in a last-ditch attempt to win back
customers Israel has employed one time
wannabe fighter pilot now high flying
executive chef Philip Blaze can I have
two avocado and shrimp with 25 years
experience Monsieur Blaze came hot from
the multi-million pound Stables of belgo
and Planet Hollywood I thought well why
not give a try you know to the
countryside of England at Planet
Hollywood I had 150 people working for
me you know so here it's a lot different
you know I've got two Three Chefs you
know we get some great feedback but the
only problem is that the guests don't
come in
even on a dead shirt like Valentine's
night out of 84 available seats only 24
have been booked but at least that means
the misses and I can get a table Happy
Valentine's Day
[Music]
from the Valentine's special menu I've
ordered a scallop and shrimp cocktail
for Mains and a Tiramisu creme brulee
for dessert sorry I decided to bring it
myself because I had trouble getting a
waiter thank you okay you're welcome
oh
microwave rice
straight away
go on
just uh
just a mess really
I've only got nice colors I just need
cooking sort of 10 seconds each side but
they're chewy with overcooked dried
prawns
there Phil's Nemesis and maito D is 25
year old A6 boy Dave bone I think you
need to have quality rather than
quantity on a nightlight tonight treat
people with the respect they want and
the special manner what the hell is your
meal seen we'll go straight to the creme
brulee I think strawberry
isn't it
so I do work here
such a dessert please probably
overcooked I'm sorry I said rubbery and
overcooked
I'm not the only one complaining I
ordered Santa
lovely
lovely it wasn't quite cooked at least
my pudding should be a safe bet it's a
French classic so Philip should be able
to make it with his eyes closed
and it looks like he has
camboding it's liquid it's the first for
me actually I've never had a running
Creme Brule I should ask for a straw
it's [__] embarrassing
oh come on it's not all right excuse me
Dave no like listening
okay
no no no no you don't look an idiot okay
someone you're a [__] [__]
okay go back to your restaurant
anglo-french relations seem to have hit
a new low
here we are all I can hear is the
[__] Chef champion in the kitchen
we made hard work of nothing
and what I didn't experience was any
passion
well I did think that uh the scalloped
dish which I was actually very very good
the ones I had were like rubber hmm
and I'm really sorry but I've never
known a Frenchman to make such a [__] to
him brilliant all my life
we got a lot of work to do
awful food bad service cool [__] you
know definitely not the place for me
Israel and Tara have sunk everything
they own into D place and they're hugely
indebted to the brewery
the odds are really stacked against them
but I like them and I also like a
challenge
[Music]
lunchtime in the kitchen is the busiest
time of the day and Philip is back to
his normal menu I'm really hoping it's a
damn side better than last night's crap
otherwise we really are in the [__]
[__]
with over 40 dishes to choose from
Philly this menu is global both in size
and choice what is that
this is salsa sauce
[Music]
everything from all day English
breakfast Hoisin noodles to Mexican
platters this is definitely more
confusion than Fusion some of it's even
served in a bread bin people don't eat
out that surely are you taking the piss
well we give it a bit of a Polish 70 of
Phillips food is brought in ready
prepared what's happened to that the
Frenchman even gets these baguettes
delivered Frozen
I'm buying in ready-made food is an
expensive false economy what's the most
popular dish today
uh the hamburgers and the crabs are they
homemade yeah yes they are
finally thank you very much
Philippe's two Sous chefs munya and
alsama are young and inexperienced they
clearly know nothing Beyond Phil's
warped Colony world and what's that in
there
split uncle
Ben's you know where do you want to be a
head chef
three years [__] me you better move your
ass
where do you want to be a head chef
well maybe in about 10 years time 10
years time yeah probably have my own
place I think that's what I would like
they may be hungry for success but if
they think this is cooking they're in
for a surprise very lumpy though isn't
it it looks like [__] porridge
the bells the bells can you tell me if
this is starter and this main crew so is
it all together
yeah please because I can't guess you
didn't take any sweats here was the
greek salad what lunchtime service
should be a quick turnaround but with
all the cock-ups the customers are lucky
to get their food within 45 minutes
and it's not held by the full-scale war
ranging between restaurant manager Dave
and Philip
what is it between you and Dave because
you hate each other right uh pretty much
yeah and when the food does eventually
make it out to the customers it comes
boomeranging back just as fast
which one
it's my mistake obviously I should have
spotted it before it went out
and it's not just the undercooked fish
that slip through Philippe's net she
just says
what's going on here the plates are
Fuller coming back and they are going
out
Wards
[__] snodgy and [__] disgusting how
many is cooked there Burgers can be
barbecued grilled or fried but the
secret to success is to cook them to
water look how thin they are we don't
cook burgers now they're not even on
order we're cooking them either for
tonight or even for tomorrow because the
thing is for tomorrow the thing is the
oven is very very slow and we can't put
it any higher than that have you lost
the plot
no have you gone a little bit [__]
bonjour no
I said how are you going to cook that
again tomorrow
uh it will be reheated in the microwave
holy mackerel
and the torturous treatment of innocent
food doesn't stop there and you deep fry
the bacon now
we do yeah
yeah like this in France
could hang you upside down from the
other tree and buy your bollocks you
know that
we're in the ship
but if we want to turn the business
around yes I I have to agree
we are in the [__] [__]
[Music]
Cafe bardi place is in deep trouble
in the last year food sales have dropped
seven thousand pounds a week and
depressedly since I arrived I found few
positives to build on it's time for
Israel to pull his head out the sand and
smell the coffee looking at the
situation I can actually confirm I'm
[__] myself I'm worried about the
situation in the kitchen the idea of
cooking there's not a lot of that going
on in there no the standards
crap and what I have identified lately
is lack of Pride yeah and a huge lack of
respect too many individuals like you've
got now will completely [__] the
business
owner for your business
no a lot of sense of Pride for the
business it starts from the top you have
to stay [__] strong on top of it
because without your determination we're
[__] and we need to turn their
attitudes around get their heads out
their [__] and [__] get this
place back on track
the animosity between Dave and Philip is
dragging the business down they're like
a whinging old couple
so on day three it's time to start
building bridges with some tried and
tested marriage guidance tactics hold
out your hand
so whilst we've got that egg in your
hand
tell Dave what you really think about it
well Dave you're just an arrogant little
bastard
uh you know you think you know
everything you're the most beautiful
you're the most perfect guy there is
and that's the bottom line
hello
I think you're talking out of your ass
aren't you because when I do try and
talk to you
if I do shout it's because you argue and
don't let me finish so from now on stop
being a stubborn [__] French bastard
because we're not gonna work until and
this place is going to go down
there's nothing that I would like more
than actually being able to work with
the manager of the restaurant and this
whole exercise is not personal
it's about business and doing your
[__] jobs
I just beg you both to continue talking
to one another
because that hasn't taken place
understand each other's jobs
no shake hands
for the better
it's not just Phil's relationship with
Dave that's worrying me
he seems to have lost any real command
of his kitchen
an efficient Brigade thrives on constant
motivation from their head chef but
munya and elsima are left to fester in
Bottle sources and Frozen deep-fried
food
mushrooms breaded mushrooms yeah they're
picking up one bad habit after another
Philip doesn't even seem to care well
being an Essex you know people tend to
like The Omelette well because this is
an Essex helmet not a French omelet it's
not a French omelette no okay
holy mackerel show me
yeah that's uh that's [__] cooked
it's time to find out what happened to
Philip Blaze executive chef
extraordinaire
I see a man in front of me at 40 years
of age French that's had bloody good
jobs before an executive [__] level
whether it's belgo or Planet Hollywood
but I don't see anything that resembles
a chef if you are buying so much food in
and it's making you look [__] yeah why
are you fighting against that chefs
fight for reputations and show the
hunger to the customers of making them
happy it's true
up to a point yes I may have given up
because I see that that's thankful hope
but I am still as hungry as I was to
actually do and create things okay well
I want to help you and I want to work
closely with you to get things back
online just to install that little bit
of [__] normality Pride you just said
it
get it back
when a business stops making money it's
tempting to stop investing in it and
it's blatantly obvious that's exactly
what Israel's done
the dining room is Tatty and the kitchen
is lacking some of the Basic Essentials
you've got to give this man the tools in
order to operate this [__] restaurant
properly I'm frustrated that we've got a
freezer full of crap and we've got
another one that doesn't work
so we've got to get our priorities right
your business you're employed as the
head chef you both have to start
speaking the same language
that's absolutely critical I hope this
is the beginning of things to change and
if you leave has felt in the past there
he's been put on the pressure to cut
Corners uh not to cut corners without
talking to me
with the lines of communication open and
the promise of vital equipment on the
horizon Phillip and I can start thinking
about the food
do not think the menu is too big
yes it is Maybe
finally we're starting to get somewhere
to pull in lunchtime diners is out with
Fusion confusion and in with a Snappy
menu tasty fresh food that can be pushed
out quick you see what I'm trying to do
I'm just trying to lift it I don't want
to get complicated these guys
aren't in a position to get anything
complicated done that's pretty obviously
and Phil's come up with a classic French
Sandwich to get our creative juices
flowing so you're quite passionate about
the [__] machine I do like it yes when
you're so passionate about something as
nice and delicious as this how can you
make that baguette with the chicken and
the plastic cheese I know this is water
for duct back for you you're a Frenchman
oh this surely must be the kind of food
you like cooking it does because I've
seen you more relaxed in the last 10
minutes than I have in three days
yeah be nice for you to give a little
bite to the guys and tell them about it
show them a little bit of sort of you
know passion at last some real food and
it smells delicious all the way from
Dijon
huh you're happy with that one aren't
you
um
very nice yeah
ultimate what do you think I I like it
baguette chicken baguette
is much better because yeah it looks
better tastes better we're gonna take a
picture why are we taking a picture
it becomes idiot proof no matter how
easy you think the sandwich is it's
still
possible to damage a business on a [__]
sandwich
in the past year Philip has already
changed the menu four times to no effect
so it's not surprising that Israel needs
a little reassurance that another new
menu is the right step if we agree that
we're going to cook it this way yeah and
it changes in and cuts Corners that is
frustrating when I talk about
reintroducing menus I'm not talking
about [__] food that's over his head
I'm talking about soups sandwiches yeah
and straightforward dishes that you can
identify that are idiot proof and
[__] delicious it does music to my
ears that's all but it's not just the
food that's been letting the place down
Dave's bone has been away to me ever
since I arrived he's taught the talk but
done little to back it up you have
fallen for the
um biggest problem any restaurant
manager has with their staff you become
their best mate
and that's pissed off a few people in
here you can't afford to run this
restaurant as your social event
otherwise mate you won't be here for
much longer turning into my own show
it's probably not the best for business
but the easiest you're running a [__]
smart
cool cafe bar new start stand apart from
your staff
it's time for a peace Summit between the
war and factions so I've asked Israel to
come up with an exercise to promote
communication and trust between the
kitchen and the front of house teams you
had your onions into it and you started
smashing yeah they're going to be making
guacamole but there's a twist
the teams are
Philip you're partnered up with David
the person in the back is actually
making the guacamole but you're all
gonna be putting a blindfold on so
you're gonna have to depend on the
person in front of you directing you I.E
we're gonna have to depend on the
restaurant helping the kitchen and the
kitchen helping the restaurant put his
blindfold on if you're good the head not
the necklace
hands behind your back three minutes
starting from
now very very soft today
as in a pinch oh pinch sorry
halfway there
eat it
point the finger so stop dots are moving
[Music]
it is right how are we doing we're done
you have to get another match stop holes
in front
okay this one
it's quite nice but nothing's mushed up
so whose fault was that money is I guess
I was the one that couldn't see
mmm not bad
nice there's no Tabasco in there Dave
and Phillips
yours are the best
I think Dave gave you more encouragement
there in the last three minutes than he
has done in two years no matter what
happens from this day on you guys have
got to get on
because of the head chef and the general
manager get on then everybody else
underneath you follows suit
to understand the importance of that
the bonding Masters one small step for
Philippe and Dave but potentially a huge
lead for the business I am never going
to put your finger in my mouth again you
put your finger no yours my finger is
Jesus
by day four Israel's ready to grab his
business by the Bulls this is his last
roll of the dice and he wants to start
with consistently good fresh food from
the kitchen
I'm Phillip for the new potatoes yes
nicely roasted
I don't tastes very nice it does tastes
bitter
they haven't gone into the fryer have
they no no I'm sure you haven't put them
in the fryer yeah
uh look mister
let me just have a quick word very very
important yeah this man is paying your
salary yeah his business is about to
close
do you understand how critical the
situation is so pay the man [__]
respect and tell the truth you have deep
fried those potatoes now a diesel one I
haven't been deep fried they are
wrinkled dehydrated and they have been
in the deep fat fryer
that's not dehydrated you're talking to
a chef and for as long as I've got a
hole in my butt big boy those [__]
potatoes have been in the deep fat fryer
don't [__] lie I know what they did
you know the oven's not even hot enough
to roast a potato we can't even cook a
[__] Burger in there they've been in
the fryer
tell the [__] truth
look they went in the oven tell him the
[__] truth
he's so adamant I've even started to
doubt my own judgment
until I track down alcimer how many
trays of potatoes did you find this
morning
I found everything here you fried all
four
and who told you to fry them
you're a chef here
why did you deep fry the potatoes
you said it earlier it's because the
oven is now when you're hot enough right
can we get back to basics now
and cut the [__] crap
sorry
but I [__] hate liars
it's not rightfully but it's me who's
asking you
the only reason I'm doing maybe these
programs because this is the last thing
I can do to save the business I want
honesty for me that's all I want don't
be ever ever be scared of looking like a
pratt
but rather be an honest part
than a liar Pratt because then you lose
self-respect my mistake
I can only apologize for this
if there's one thing worse than the chef
who can't cook
it's the chef who tells pork is
my workload has just doubled
and there's only one way out of this
kilometers cul-de-sac
to get this place back online
we're gonna have to close for two days
there's no way or an earth we're ever
gonna get the food back up to scratch
while you're sending what you're sending
out
I need 48 hours we'll work on tidying up
the dining room painting every member of
Staff working
for that goal to get it fresh and then
two days in the kitchen
to get it on track
how do you feel about Israel we can't
afford not to take money but
we can't afford not to have a future
business yeah I think something that we
need to stop is a [__] I need people
to be honest with me Philip are you
ready for this if it is to make the
business better I'm I'm 100 on ten
percent behind it's not just the
Kitchener yeah yeah but I'm talking
about the dining room as well yeah
there's a serious you know Improvement
there to take place it's a lack of pride
a lack of Pride and the potatoes was a
prime [__] example cut the [__]
you hit the nail on the [__] head
and those are pulling on the rope stay
and work those aren't interested in
pulling on the [__] rope [__] off
[Music]
day five at the place in Essex I've
established the Sheffield to be kept on
a very short leash and his food is
beyond tragic
so for the first time in four years
Israel has shut the place down
um just returning your call
with no customers we can throw
everything at revitalizing the image
and most importantly a god-awful menu
it's mine
I'm nobody else now it's a fresh start
let's get it back on the road and very
soon we'll be on the motorway
hey
when a Russian drastically changes his
food it's important to back it up with
the right atmosphere
a couple of coats of paint is an easy
way to Dazzle your customers and give
you a second chance
today is your spank it in the whole
place back to Luke sharp crisp clean and
nice and walking and saying wow yeah I
like it
the kitchen's been scrubbed clean and
the oven's fixed at last
but that's not all for Phil it seems all
these no else have come at once
shaking
I'm actually going to have a kitchen
with proper equipment
Israel and Tara must be bleeding
somewhere
this one's going home with me I'm
sleeping with it tonight not Dave
from now on plastic sauces and frozen
foods are bad the new menu will be
cooked strictly from fresh ingredients
and our first buy is a four kilo ham
drizzle
the honey and the brown sugar over
it's a delicious steel at a cost of just
10 pounds and with a little lateral
thinking it's a potential money spinner
is it gone already fried eggs with ham
caught me sure yeah and ham soup can you
see just how much money you can generate
from one ham
yes surrounded by all this fresh food
there's a tangible change of energy in
Philip's two young chefs
the seasoning is it's quite even it's
quite nice it's not so much
while munya tends the soup alsama is
carefully preparing a pot of delicious
bubble and squeak what do you think
a little bit more salt yeah good I'm
glad you said that
um
fresh food
mmm [__] hell they're crazy in your
[__] hands you know you're supposed
to be guiding them through this you know
that yeah
how many big chefs did you work for when
you were their age
quite a few yeah and did they kick your
ass oh yes yeah do you hate them for it
I love them already you love them for it
do you think they love you when you show
them nothing
I think now I'm gonna learn it
you've made that from start to finish
before you taste it you know what I'm
gonna do take a [__] photograph
that's your reference yes at last it
feels like we're getting somewhere the
chests are infused and the dying room
has been transformed almost beyond
recognition
but as it stands the outside of the
building is selling all our hard work
short building's beautiful you know so
show it off but we've got to get rid of
all the tacky [__] stuck to the front of
it now that you mention it and you see
it from a different point of view we go
we're promoting drinks we're saying
cocktail night Thursday night and we'll
go our menu displayed on a tattoo yeah
there yeah you're waking up to it and
I'm glad you're starting to open your
[__] eyes because it really is
important and you know the [__]
worldly Place well you know that's got
to go in the bin I think it's been
consensus we're going for um saracens
Cafe Bar
yeah [__] perfect Israel it seems is
now on a crusade to bring the place back
from the dead now get out of there and
tell the world about it we've got just
one day before the Customs return to a
fully booked grand reopening
everything depends on the Kitchen
perfect in each and every new dish on
the menu
fried eggs turn down the gas I don't
want the yolks broken okay they may be
easy peasy but consistent quality will
be the key to ensure repeat business you
have to get in there and really
concentrate yeah this is so [__] easy
the centerpiece for our menu is going to
be the most famous buddy in the world
the club sandwich
when I started cooking yeah I had to
make these for a living every day the
same
every day the same
in just 12 hours time the chefs in the
front of house have got to function as a
tight-knit well-oiled machine
that's the ham roasted
and a minor miracle has occurred
salmon fish sauce Dave and Philip are
communicating
they all look really nice
the food is looking 200 better but to
please a lunch hour crowd tomorrow the
grub will have to fly out
I need to be sure these boys are really
on their toes I'll do the toast when
that goes to 12
.
go three times
quick I'll do the bread quick quick
what are you doing first
come on tomorrow we're fully booked for
lunch
fully booked Philip it's not funny you
know that yeah
yes I also wants anyone to talk about
putting bacon on who else is going to
put their bacon on here when
tonight
yes here we go
hey
anyone thought about starting their
French fries
um
[Music]
look at the speed of you
fantastically fast is the executive chef
gonna come in last
time no that's it that's yours
[Music]
don't quit big boy do not quit you never
ever throw the towel in on service
just come up to the hot plate and
accidentally drop your plate drop it now
drop it oh [__]
man damn [__] Hey listen all three of
you well done
that was [__] excellent yeah the
speed working under pressure and
concentrating was phenomenal and the
best sandwich
is yours Philip
great without him even knowing it I've
just managed to demo the executive chef
to the club sandwich Chef now tomorrow
we've actually got a chance of [__]
surviving a very busy lunch
10 a.m launch day
with 70 customers booked in for lunch no
one can afford to be ill-prepared I'll
be running checks and checking out the
pictures all right it's a delicate
balance we've got a new menu
are you ready for this it's a big day
don't [__] it up the waiting staff are
only just up to speed and one week link
could bring Israel's last remaining
business tumbling about his ears
I think it'll go well I'm nervous
um
because everybody is on edge it's like
opening a brand new business uh a time
before and I know how disastrous it can
be the first thing I've got to say is
the place
it's default it's gone yeah welcome to
the usas Cafe Bar yes we've worked
together as a team we understand each
other yeah there's going to be several
customers that are going to be going for
a 30 minute lunch that's a soup and a
sandwich a soup and a salad whatever
they prefer within 30 minutes I can
guarantee if they leave under 30 minutes
they'll be back next week three or four
times between Monday and Friday
get it right yeah
this is it without you
I can't do it consistency Alsina yeah
Bingo can you order two tomato soup from
two sandwiches that's the the quick deal
yeah 30 minutes yeah well tell the
Brigade The Lunch deal is cheap at just
six pound fifty is the bacon onto the
club sandwich it's a toasting it's going
in now to make it worth it rails while
Dave must fill the restaurant twice over
which means turning the tables fast this
has to go like clubs
three more minutes excellent good um two
seconds
a new potato
where did that come from
I know we've got to push it out and move
our ass but we're not going to serve
that like that what's burning
turn it over medium
we've been over this menu time and time
again but monyo and Altima are already
buckling under the pressure how many how
many eggs how
for birthday
privilege to burst their own [__]
yolk not you yes and there's only three
orders on
press the lettuce and vinaigrette on the
Welsh rabbits all pissing over the plate
where's the chef
by 12 30 the restrooms full to bursting
do we have a waiting list no it's all
done to the kitchen now one more club
sandwich another throwy bread but
another burger with chips and baked
beans serious please service please
where's the rest of the fish tanks I
said to take some out of the freezer it
seems my super basic menu Isn't basic
enough for this team of numb skulls
no they're not cooked
[Music]
that Fryer's gone out and they've been
trying to cook chips in cold oil
[Music]
can't let one problem bring the whole
operation to its knees now we just fry
the potato wedges in a pan though
yeah almost like a roasted potato all
together six that soup the orders are
stacking up and the Panic has already
set in all these new orders some rice on
this soup please you mean chime yeah
just give me the freaking rest that's
fine thank you and now there's a problem
with the tickets
tables four five five
table five I don't have all the
communication has gone out the window
and the customers are left in the dark
as to why their food is taking so long
we have an hour for lunch so obviously
we have to try and fit the food in
within the hour so I've just had to
phone the office and tell them we're
going to be a bit late I'm gonna get
back to work in two minutes
those that are getting their food are
loving it but 20 minutes later there's
no resolve to the ticket confusion I
think it's gone I know it's disappeared
yeah that's why there's such a problem
because they've been waiting outside
Phil's only guidance through this mess
are his tickets but it seems everyone's
had their hands on them
[Applause]
and if a chef loses an order it's like
an air traffic controller losing a plane
they've took it they didn't bring
[Applause]
and this one's going down
what's going on why is the food coming
back
on table seven here that you're giving
me that was gone long time ago so we've
already sent the table oh come on right
now we don't need to [__] repeat the
order
huh that's because the waiter leaves
don't no don't blame don't blame the
waiter on the pick no everything I'm
going for a cigarette I had it hello
what do you mean you're going out for a
cigarette
bad enough of this Chef yeah we're
thinking you cannot just disappear there
is enough okay when somebody does a
mistake I'm the first to admit it but
not but when I'm covering for someone
else's [__] but he's okay I had enough
of this
okay
you can't just walk out for cigarette
Philip I'm sorry the shit's at the fan
I'm here to help
let's get back on here straight away and
start again let's go come on it seems
Israel believes Phillips not entirely to
blame for this Fiasco why do I have a
waitress going into the kitchen
with a problem with our Dave now you've
been told there is a manager on the
floor and that manager should be on the
ball with every single [__] table one
stage are they have to cover the coffee
have they had to drink how long since
they order that's what I want out of it
stops here
yeah exactly I was wrong Israel's right
as a manager Dave should have this
situation well in hand you're in charge
of tearing the food in and out you need
to know on stage
the floor now yeah get off the floor now
okay get off the floor now fine
use the back door please
catalog of disasters has taken their
toll Israel's had to give away over a
hundred pounds worth of complimentary
food and drink and to avoid further
embarrassment is decided to shut the
service down after just one sitting
[Music]
minutes
one hour and 20 minutes
and the [__] gonna happen Saturday
[Music]
tomorrow we're gonna have to get our
[__] together that's for sure it's been
a real disappointment for everyone but
we can learn from today's harsh lessons
mayor suggest you know only take the
customers you can do and then each and
every day build it because it tells it
is a small close knit
town
and if word spreads that you've reopened
and the food's not as good as you think
it should be then they won't come back
huh Phil's clearly been through the mill
these last few days even though I didn't
want to admit it I have actually
lost part of
the passion which I had does it become
painful trying to cook with no feelings
it becomes an automaticism will you find
that passion again it has come back
already
well I didn't think that lunchtime when
you walked out for a cigarette but you
came back that was the most important
thing you know yeah and I appreciated
that yeah I I don't want to do it
without you
it's not my kitchen yeah
yeah perhaps one of the toughest weeks
I've ever had in my [__] career oh
yeah
oh [__] yeah definitely
but
get it back on track
that's the most important thing Israel
keep on them yeah breathing down their
necks yeah
very much thank you bye thank you Gordon
thank you guys Chef thank you yes
do you really hate me
can I pass from the comments
bye guys yes hey thank you I'll be back
thank you I'll be back yes
bring on your potatoes
bye
oh
you can breathe my plate
[Music]
it's been six weeks since I was last in
Chelmsford and I've heard rumors that
something strange has been going on at
the saracens head Cafe Bar
what happened to sarson's head in the
week I spent at the place it didn't take
long to suss out that D stood for
Dreadful
boy those [__] potatoes have been in
the Deep Fat prior the owners were in
Dire Straits if I don't do something
drastic then you know this business will
go down the pan and the staff were
dysfunctional from now on stop being a
stubborn [__] French bastard we need
to turn their attitudes around and if I
can get this place back on track over
the longest seven days of my life we
injected some passion into the food no
that's it that's yours there
and got the team eating out of each
other's hands
it wasn't perfect I'm gonna get back to
work in 10 minutes
but I really felt that sarazon's cafe
bar was well on the road to recovery all
three of you well done
that was [__] excellent
the latest news from inside is
unbelievable I thought things couldn't
get any worse but they just have
um God how strange I mean really really
strange
um Israel's no longer there the place
has gone in to receive a ship she said
two weeks ago it doesn't belong to him
the brewery of taking it back and he's
been kicked out
the brewery has put the lease of the
place up for sale and Israel and Tara
are out on their ears
ironically the one person I suspected
might not be here is here Philip Blaze
executive chef extraordinaire it's a
very very sad you know what a short
story
shock yeah and everything you put into
it and what the guy's done and just yeah
all gone down the drain basically
looking very clean obviously not making
many club sandwiches what's the time
down to we are it's one of the best
seller what best in the cup machine
what's coming out the quickest
the club Center the club sandwich
so it appears that things were really
starting to happen at the place after I
left and the food sales were on the up
hello Israel hello
um I did not expect to see you here you
know that but it seems it was too little
too late for Israel and Tara
[__] yeah very well how are you feeling
all right it's a goodie to get it
together and we did the town was bassing
with with Samson's head being able to
produce the quality of the food that we
were producing nice simple yeah the
people were coming in and said it was
delicious it was perfect
they didn't have long to reap the
benefits shortly after I left the
brewery took the business out of Israel
and Tara's hands and it just happened on
the spur of the moment that you're at
work and all of a sudden bang well we
didn't even know we were going to be
asked for the keys mortgage
all at the wrong time you're out okay
yeah on your ass you're seven months
pregnant seven eight months pregnant
eight months pregnant I mean this is not
the kind of predicament I you know I
expected to see
um what did you lose Israel lost
obviously more than I did but mine was
inheritance from my mother and my
grandmother the fact that I was naive
and I didn't know how Corporate big
Nationals work and and the world of the
accountants and the solicitors and all
of that crap I didn't know anything
about
I know how to deserve people I know how
to make them smile I know how to deal
with a complaint I know how to deal with
the kitchen I don't know how to deal
with
business you know transactions of that
matter no and that's where it hurts
I feel so sorry for them and I still
can't quite believe what's happened good
luck with the baby take care Israel and
Tara had genuinely thought they could
keep the business going right but sadly
after calling the spokesperson for the
brewery it all becomes crystal clear
okay
um sounds now like the brewery we're
only acting on their best interest
by accepting the highest bid and I think
Israel has been slightly naive
no matter how good the food is
you've really got to understand every
aspect of your business and the areas
you don't understand seek advice
before you get [__]
[Music]
six and a half minutes
that's not bad does it taste as good as
it looks
[Music]
very nice
you have got your passion back you know
that that is [__] delicious
[Music]